hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to three
scary
games
i'm assuming that elixion just doesn't
want to make those sound effects so i
made them for him so
make that sound good there lexie and
scare him good you know how this is
don't give me any says
[Music]
i'll leave
by the way congratulations
oh
oh la mao come over what
i'm
i don't know how uh what is happening
oh
i think this one's called a walk home
walk home not a wacom alexian make me
write put a in there
oh fun i can't hear anything
oh there we go
huh hi
all right let's go for it it seems
awfully cheerful for being a horror game
oh there we go
look at that face
bye
later dude
oh okay
oh
look at this fun night out that we whoa
what
uh
okay
well now
all right anyway that's that's fun but i
guess i'm walking home man this is a
slow walk and there is no run
which i guess if i was actually walking
home
i wouldn't be running
yeah okay i'm gonna take a shortcut
through the woods
that's what i'm doing
hi
light
what am i looking at what is this
what oh
oh
did i go the wrong way did i just go
into the woods like an idiot as if it
was something what
[Music]
what do you mean he saw he saw what
what did he saw
go i'll go all right i'm going i don't
know what he saw
what did he saw
i don't know if i was supposed to find
that
i don't know if it was my destiny to do
hi
what are you doing there
i see you i see you i see you
hi
you okay there ow buddy
okay
some dude getting in his car
what am i doing
i meant what i said what did you what
what
what did you said what what got said who
said what
got him
speeder
where's my house how do i get home
well this is disconcerting
what did i why did
i'm sorry what did i just take a picture
of
oh
okay
i'm just gonna barge into this house
oh god i have a knife
we're ending two of three what
what
what was that what do you mean ending
i didn't even began i hardly even begun
all right okay
bye my friend
by my good friend
goodbye good friend
i'm taking pictures
there we go
oh that's he saw he saw what he saw what
did he saw
and
man
mikhail was here oh hi i see you i see
you i say no no no no no no no no no
no no no that was what that noise
[Music]
i mean what i said yeah i meant what i
said too
i meant what i said
i meant what you said and you meant what
i said
look at this lovely vista that i missed
the vista that i missed
birds
i'm just addicted
i'm just addicted to taking taking
pictures taking pictures on my phone
that's all that's that's it
oh oh
what is this
what's this
what is this oh god
oh god
oh no what am i looking at i can't tell
a knife
it's a knife
it's a knife and a pile of horrible
carcasses
and i'm hoping that's all it is ah that
hurts my eyes
well time to wander into this house
again
hi
i wanna get a picture of you i'm gonna
get a picture over i got you i got you i
gotcha you thought that you were safe no
no way
good thing i live so close to my buddy
huh i knew it
oh i see you you think i don't see you
oh i see you
and now it's corrupted he saw
what did he saw
[Music]
oh
we are done oh where are we
are we
oh
so we're done now
oh we're just done is that it
okay well that's new
oh what is that
missing dog
missing cat
i'm betting if i go back in my house
here it's just gonna be the same thing
however
what happens if i go back now it's a
long slow walk but it might be worth it
or it might not be worth it at all
i can't really believe this happened
like i had my suspicions but um
known him for many years but that i
really didn't expect this
i can't really look at him the same way
i've got to do something
what
oh
lightning okay so going back did nothing
but i found this um fun music
okay
what the f what the f what the what the
f what the f
what the f what the
what the frick
i don't like it or i'm just gonna go
back i don't know if it's gonna be a
different ending though
oh hi
no i didn't do it but this is the same
thing what do i do differently
what do i do differently
so for this one
you guys might have to um uh figure it
out because apparently i don't know but
my friend knows that i murdered someone
and i don't know how to get to the true
ending but if you want to play walk home
it's in the description check it out
unfortunately i have to move it on so
i'll leave this mystery up to you report
back in the comments what it was thanks
moving on
welcome to dark hotel
it's a hotel in the dark or the hotel is
dark or the hotel didn't pay as
powerball and we don't have any lights
oh god my eyeballs
oh
okay
i can lean
why does this hotel look like the hotel
from uh
the hotel
hotel hotel you remember the hotel with
jimmy why can't i remember that name
that's a great game i got to check in if
they're making more games
because that was dope as hell am i uh
am i stupid
hi
you all right
you need someone to hold your hand
oh
never mind
i rescind my offer
i'm in the bathroom i can't open my door
[Music]
oh
oh is that blood a shockingly realistic
looking blood
hello
okay no one's home
i guess
[Music]
lady did my rescue
is that you
hi
okay
oh hi
six
whoa
hi
okay
six
everyone keep that in mind
six no
six
some stairs seem to be missing didn't
dawn on me that the downstairs stairs
are also missing
okay is that the door that i needed at
the end of the hallway there's a
flashing light right there is that a
clue or is that where i came from
huh
[Music]
oh
oh yeah the hallway uh
okay
here i thought that this game was gonna
be like oh this is freaking spooky oh
this seems well made
a little did i know
was it gonna be a case of the lumbering
big lady
all right anyway
hey lady
you're an old lady dimitrescu
i don't need to respect your power it's
funny because like
i've you know i'm not wait you know i
don't want to make a judgment i don't
want to say like this game is not good
because i don't know that yet
okay i know it
six it's another six
six
guys i'm sensing a pattern i don't want
to criticize like i i poke fun because
you guys understand yeah i've seen a lot
of horror games in my time and i know
that like this is it looks good
i just got some cool things happening
but also if those are like what the
scares are gonna be then
it's gonna need a little something more
is the ceiling wet that's this game this
looks so beautiful but i think it might
just be a factor of like that this is on
a really good game engine
and that's why it looks good you know
with reflections and whatnot however the
lighting don't look right like something
ain't right about the lighting there i
don't think this is supposed to make the
lampshade look
like that i don't think that's how any
lighting works in any environment
however what a high you plankin
you okay
oh it's a body bag i thought it was a
dude just like laying like on the ground
like okay
hey come back
oh no
it's another six oh it's my room
oh
inventory do i have an inventory i
didn't know i had one
okay what do i do with it
oh
hi
more blood in the hallway hi
oh
well i'll just close that door up i
don't need to go in there
there's no need all right fine the
strobe
oh i fell off
[Music]
right
okay you're not actually supposed to
scare me i have rendered judgment on
your spooks
and i am unimpressed
what is up here is this just nothingness
is this unfinished okay
i wasn't supposed to go up that way i
understand that now
i'm leaving
right where's uh where's lady
domitrescu
oh can i go down now no i cannot go down
okay well
i'm uh unsure of where i'm supposed to
go now
perhaps i was supposed to go back in my
room and find something else
cause i got a key but i'm not exactly
sure what the key is for you know what i
mean i don't really know what the deal
is with the key
and the sixes
i'm guessing i need to unlock another
six in my room because that's going to
be good for me somehow
okay so i have a key it must need me to
use this key somewhere but i don't
recall using the other key before
so uh i guess we just got to keep trying
until we find the right spot
hmm
oh
oh my god
[Music]
oh i didn't actually come over here
ah i see i was supposed to look at this
oh
key
[Music]
i'll take it oh i put mike oh i put the
key oh
oh my god strobe good god elixie and put
up put a flash warning at the beginning
of this holy hey are you in a pit
is there room for one more
oh yes there is
and i'm dead
which just goes to show when you're
trapped in a hotel don't jump in the
hole with all the bodies in it or else
you're gonna be in a hole with a bunch
of bodies in it and that's no good for
anybody not bad had a lot of flaws
however i will forgive them because
it was fun
i liked it it was not bad
last stop station 66
don't watch i'm gonna watch it you can't
tell me what to do i'm gonna watch it
and i'm gonna drink more water you can't
tell me what to do
[Music]
okay
hi
don't mind me walking through the train
real slow
perfectly normal
oh
okay oh
hello
hi
i guess i'm here now
i'm much taller than i was before hi
you're the same person who was on the
train before hi how are you okay all
right cold children
step back and stay the hell away from me
fair fair enough
fair fair is fair i apologize
hi how are you doing
i invade people's personal spaces i
squibb my job this place is a bloody
mess
if i could i would quit any day now
okay
hi
whoa
hey
how's it going no need to be so forward
wow
uh okay
goodbye then
oh hi puppy
puppy
oh hi puppy oh what the hell
what the hell
hi pop
oh
what
okay hello
oh
i'm going to be sick what the hell's
going on who did it yeah good question
okay yeah no i'll take that a bloody
kitchen knife i probably shouldn't touch
it yeah well i did um
okay
that's fine
that's perfectly fine
that is a hundred percent fine
hey no one go back there and look at
that stuff
that's not normal
and i call the polite no hey lady you
were pretty right about the whole stay
away from me thing
uh probably wise
wise decisions where am i going why am i
doing it hello
you can hot
why would i
why would i want to hide in a locker
damn it rusty piece of needs a key
you're telling me that i can't get out
of this subway
until i get a key
you know also you're not doing a very
good job no wonder you want to quit okay
so i need to find a key let me guess the
key is on the body that's back here oh
hi what are you doing down there you
vandalizing all right um
hey do you have a key
i know this is strange nice brain
oh
what happened
okay
i don't know what that's about but i
don't see a key so
still got a lot of issues but i'm afraid
now that those those buttons are so tiny
i'm afraid that the detail of the key is
going to be like
itty bitty bitty
like itty bitty bitty bitty wherever it
might be
oh
oh oh
oh yeah oh
hi
[Music]
oh
oh right right okay
hi
oh
oh hi
hi oh hi
oh hi okay
oh
hi
any of you see wow is that a key
thank you
i'll take that
have a good day sir
have a good day ma'ams
oh boy
ah goodbye
okay
hey hey hey no none of that
hey uh oh god they're gone okay i'm
gonna hide in the locker which i know
what i can do
i know i can do this
oh my god
okay well hey dude from outlast how are
you doing um
so about this uh
i'm hiding in this locker you couldn't
possibly get me
you couldn't possibly get me you fool
and i'll run i'll run i'm running
i made it
shockingly uh maybe i should have gone
down that place with the
uh where you were
there you are ah here i am
here i am
okay so what am i supposed to do about
this pursuit i have a feeling he's just
like always on my ass
okay are you gonna wait a minute
are you kidding me
what
what oh god this oh
oh
why
why would you do that
why would you have that like that why
would you in the world would you do that
why would you have the reset behind like
a 45 second intro sequence also how do
you get away from the dude well time to
hit the old dusty trail
so i do do i just go right for it hey i
see that
did you guys just that thing just plow
through them
i'm scared
hello
it's me again hi can i have this thank
you oh i should have just gone through
the gate wait i'm dumb oh
[Music]
oh there he is
okay it's fine that's fine
here i am me little pig okay i just go
through the gate right
i open i open i open oh my god are you
kidding me
i'm through i'm through
i'm definitely succeeding i i'm
definitely seeing all the important
thing oh god oh god there you are
[Music]
well they can't all be winners you know
that's just the way this game goes
i gave it a second try and that's all a
try it needs to go you don't need to
give anything third chances you
sometimes can give things second chances
when you feel like it but
i don't feel like giving that a third
chance i don't feel like it you know i
don't feel like it maybe i'm dum-dum but
you know it's at the place that you
could hide i couldn't really hide from
it i tried and then i tried to get away
from the dude by opening the door and i
almost didn't make it because it opened
away that i didn't think that it would
open and i
look at me i got back to the corner
because where else was i supposed to run
and ah good
that was the last stop that's the moral
of the game the last stop if you guys
want to see this game to completion you
can check out the link in the
description below and play for yourself
maybe there's a grander mystery that i'm
not seeing
and only you will find it out
so this has been three
scary
schemes
how do you do like an explosion but it's
a jump scare do that do that lexington
you got it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching i have plenty more scary games
in a playlist that's in the end card
that's going to show up right about now
click on it and you will see the
delights that is my scary games playlist
click it